(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Hannah I am your
friendly neighborhood wine mom,
oh hi I didn't see you there.
And if you are like me you believe that
one glass of wine at 8 pm
makes you a better mom.
So pour yourself one and
let's talk about stuff.
The best part is you don't even have
to have kids to be a wine mom.
We're gonna have some Chardonnay
that is the unofficial
official wine of all wine moms.
Okay, now I'm ready (laughs).
Here's why I'm drinking tonight,
my son is obsessed with the movie that's
out right now called BFG.
But somehow in his four year old brain
it's getting all scrambled
and my sister-in-law
finally took him to see it on Sunday
and come Monday I find out
that he's telling everyone,
"Oh my auntie took me to
see CPS over the weekend."
And for those of you who don't know
what CPS stands for it is
Child Protective Services.
So now I have everybody thinking that
my sister-in-law is taking my son to see
Child Protective Services
because I am a terrible mother.
So let's talk about the
best and worst things
about having kids, kids
are the most beautiful
creatures on the planet
my kids are the most
wonderful humans I've ever met in my life,
that being said the first word
that I think about when or no,
so that being said the first
word that comes to mind
when I think about parenting is shit.
The first five or so years of your life
you're being shit on literally--
- [Voiceover] The first
years of their life.
- Oh the first five or
so years of their life
you're being shit on literally
and then from there on out
you get shit on emotionally.
I have a four year old and a one year old,
so I'm halfway through wiping two butts.
Then when it finally comes time to wipe
your own butt you don't
even get to do that alone,
my four year old likes to sit and watch me
actually both of them
like to sit and watch me.
And then when I say I'd like some privacy
my four year old will go, "Oh okay."
He'll shoo the one year old out,
close the door, and sit back down.
Okay dude whatever.
But shit is not the only bodily fluid that
comes out of these kids
there's just so much
wetness like my kids
think that I want them
to hand me their boogers, okay.
And then when they vomit it's like
they go out of their way to
vomit on something important.
So my son will run out onto the couch
to vomit on this fabric couch.
You were in the bathroom, why, how?
But even when they're doing
that I'm proud of them.
Even when they puke everywhere
and I'm cleaning this up
I'm like needy in vomit,
knee-deep in vomit.
I'm like I am proud of you because I see
that you ate your whole dinner,
I see broccoli in here,
you ate some veggies, nice.
So next (laughs).
I can't be drunk because
it's just one glass
I'm not even done so, I'm
just, this is just me.
Next, so when you have
kids you become accustomed
to constant noise it's like you
kind of train yourself to zone it out.
Once you finally get your silence,
(crickets chirping)
it's terrifying, something
terrible is happening,
there is poop on the walls for sure.
There's crayon on something,
someone's eating my lipstick.
So one time it was silent and
my son was in the bathroom
dunking the bath towels into the toilet
and then sucking on them,
why would you do that?
Are you thirsty?
Does it taste good?
Is there something I'm missing
about this toilet water?
So you can't win, you
finally get your silence
and it's awful.
Hold on.
Just a little bit more.
That was a really small glass
that I poured myself at first.
Next, the cost kids are so expensive.
There's swim lessons, there's
new shoes every other week,
their feet grow so fast,
I don't understand how.
It's like hobbits.
They just like take and take and take
all your money and then they
don't even appreciate it.
Like my son eats all organic.
I spend all this extra money
buying him organic food.
So I make him his organic
bread, turkey, sandwich
he'll ask for the crust to be cut off.
So the other morning I cut the crust off
then all of the sudden he decided
in that time I was cutting the crust
that he doesn't want the
crust cut off anymore.
So I serve him the sandwich and he's like,
"Oh my God, Mom."
Meltdown, flop on the floor wiggle around.
So I take the crust and
I'm like shoving them
like squeezing them
trying to get the mustard
to like stick them back on.
But no that's not gonna do,
he doesn't even want to
see the crust anymore
it's too traumatizing for him.
So I eat them because that's pretty much
the lunch I have these days.
How dare you Mom for eating my crust,
I actually wanted it all along.
You can't win (laughs).
And finally, why?
Your child is going to ask, "Why?"
To every mundane little thing you say.
That grass is green, "Why?"
Because of chlorophyll, "Why?"
I don't remember eighth grade biology,
and it makes realize how little
you know about the world.
But on the other hand
you have this opportunity
and this chance to make
something beautiful.
It's basically like
learning from your life
and making something
better for somebody else.
I can't think of something that holds
any more meaning than that.
All I can hope is that I
don't fuck it up (laughs).
So that's all for now,
I have about two sips
left of this and that's my cue to lay down
and melt into the couch
with a nice crappy TV show.
Until next time, I'm Hannah
your neighborhood wine mom,
and I'll see you later.
You won't want to see me like this, go.
My mom never...
punished me for burping,
that was like the one thing
that she didn't think was rude.